hi my name is Jim Downey and I feel
entirely Unapologetic about being Conan
O'Brien's friend
and let me explain let me explain okay
there are there are many many uh figures
in our society who contribute an
enormous amount to our culture and
people who have unconventional
personal lives
um and and yet they're they seemed
exempt from criticism
um you know uh Jeffrey Epstein wait a
minute
wait a minute no
no I said Jeffrey Epstein I see it no
one no one you know uh uh criticizes him
and yet oh wait a minute I have to
apologize for the fact that I know Conan
O'Brien wait a minute wait a minute is a
double standard wrong hold on okay hold
on but hold on much has been said much
has been said about Jeffrey Epstein
Terrible Things Jeff I'm talking about
Jeff Epstein the New York financier
yes we're talking about the same Jeff
Epstein yes no yes I what I never I
never heard oh it was a big story in the
news huge no yes for you to say no one
ever yes chef Steve yes the financier
the island yes he had an island that
I've never been to yeah
I I'm pretty sure with respect if there
was some news about Jeff Epstein I would
have heard no I
don't know it was
it was Jeff Epstein is I have to tell
you he's gone he's dead what do you mean
he's dead he's dead he's dead sorry nice
try if Jeff is Jeff Epstein if Jeff
Epstein were deceased I'm pretty sure I
would know about it now I I meant I've
not
probably since the pandemic I have not
talked to him that would make sense that
would make sense I've been dead for a
number of years yeah I'll tell you
there's one easy way let's call Julian
Maxwell no we're not calling jalaine
Maxwell one okay he's in prison she's
imprisoned for crimes she committed with
Jeff Epstein
chilean's in prison yes stop calling her
how do you know these people
I'm
your friend you you know what
I I
whatever you whatever your it doesn't
matter what you do in your private
attention I don't do anything in my
private life okay but anyway I'm your
friend all right well thank you for the
worst I make no apology for the worst
worst introduction to this podcast I've
ever heard uh now I'm gonna put the
focus on you sir
because I'm going to tell you something
all right there are some listeners this
may shock you who may say I don't know
of this Jim Downey because we're
listened to by billions of people around
the world
a lot of people in Asia
Pacific grim countries and they may not
be familiar with Jim Downey and I want
to explain to them right now
that you are considered
the greatest comedy writer
possibly
of the mid to late 20th century
petering out very rapidly in the early
2000s yeah when you just hit a wall uh
you uh you brought me to Saturday Night
Live as a young pup you launched so many
careers uh you are intimidatingly funny
and you are uh referred to by many
comedians as the great great comedy
writer the great comedy writer that we
all Revere and you're just gonna have to
accept that right now hey Sona think of
all the amazing things in life that are
expressions of just you yeah I mean like
the chocolate that you had on your face
when you came in because you just ate
that what was it you were eating I was
eating a giant cookie giant cookie yeah
and that's so Sona okay or that song you
stream over and over again it's just so
you what's that song For You Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star yeah but it's for my
boys I know still it's nice okay or you
know that podcast that comedy podcast
you just gotta listen to yeah Conan
O'Brien needs a friend is that what you
listen to in your spare time yeah I love
it everything that makes you you makes
all the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strong away I feel about it you go to
choose the plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary we're going to
start from that premise
and fantastic comedy writer who has
influenced many careers and written many
sketches that are beloved what do you
think of that well that's that's very
kind of you I mean I um I just um
I I the only thing I I would say I mean
I you know that they're funnier comedy
they're better comedy writers than me I
but I you know I I'm good enough that I
could you know play with them I I just
felt like who would you think who do you
think was better than you well I mean
there's I mean Robert smile is a
brilliant guy Roberts Michael Jackson
and I'm saying this listen I'm going to
say this I'm a good friend of Roberts
Robert was the original head writer on
my late night show and Robert and I are
good friends but I tell him this almost
every day he's a piece of okay he
couldn't write his way out of a wet
paper bag Jack Handy I didn't even know
he was a comedy writer
you you
could have been the greatest ever if you
weren't so lazy
I mean some weeks it was it was all it
was all I could do to get you to show up
to work I'm sorry I know it's like Conan
it's Wednesday the others have been here
since Monday I'm tired I'm I'm in a show
everyone did a show last week that is a
spot on impression and Jim I had other
interests you know I got into
glassblowing and it was something that I
enjoyed and I made you a beautiful
beautiful glass Beaker this is something
that I pursued on my in my spare time I
I I have that Beaker it's it's a it's a
treasured possession I will uh I will
tell you that yes Robert smeagle also
one of the greats of all time Jack candy
we could play this game forever but
I just want to walk people through your
pedigree you come to Saturday Night Live
at almost the beginning
1976 uh you're there for though that
formative four of those five seasons
that begin that show really the nuclear
bomb blast with the classic cast you're
there you were very young when you were
hired you were right out of college yeah
from a little 22 22 and your first day
of work was also Bill Murray's first day
of work is that that's right we we
shared an office for four years
and uh and I I came the Chevy's last
two weeks were like my first two weeks
so we kind of overlapped there and um
yeah that was a that was
I wish that it hadn't
been my first two years of adulthood
because it was a very strange way to
enter
adulthood you know I I didn't appreciate
all the stuff that was going on around
me at the time right and um I uh would
love to
to to get to you know reconfigure those
early years I mean you're there John
Belushi's on the cast
I remember you telling me once oh and
then he got into you know he
he started coming by with records and
playing us all these old you know Stacks
records his Blues records and he'd sing
them and you acted annoyed when it
became the Blues Brothers became this
massive Title Wave but you had this
different perspective which is I I
thought I mean The Blues Brothers
um I just said Danny
Aykroyd always he understood that it was
it was kind of a joke it was a goofy
kind of thing to do although the first
time I saw it I saw it as I mean it was
really a sketch to me Danny was a great
music John became he got very very
serious took about and he thought of
himself as a musician and and Danny was
actually really good harmonica player
and and and dancer and so Danny
um that began as a warm-up act yes for
the show and uh so audiences that would
come in to see us Saturday Night Live
just to warm them up that say her these
goofy guys The Blues Brothers and it was
really kind of a comedy sketch almost
that you you get them in the you get to
bring the audiences in the show tapes
live at 11 30. and um the audience is
the doors close at 11. so the um you
have to have the crew there and working
at they're mixing the sound they're
doing lots of notes and you sort of have
to keep them entertained
um and so um we would have it's it's all
it was a tradition at the show that it
were that it would be done by by cast
members
who had like hidden talents you know
like in later years uh we would have
Maya Rudolph and anagastire sing
together and um but in that in that
stage I mean I can't remember
everything we did in the years before
The Blues Brothers sort of formed but
initially
I mean Danny may have a different take
on it but um it was um
it was it was definitely like a comedy
thing we were having fun with it and the
audience loved it because we had
our house band is I know you know
incredible some of the most incredible
like
you had to know a fair bit about music
to write but it would be like wait a
minute the Howard Johnson his YouTuber
player the Lou Marini the AL Rubin the
you know yeah the David Sanborn that was
our house band yeah and our that
that was Howard Shore was the band
director then Paul Shaffer was the
keyboard player
um and uh Steve Jordan yeah who's the
drummer now the Stones drummer you know
um or is he isn't he is he I think I
think he is I stopped following the
stones in about 1966. did they do much
after 66 I think so yeah I mean I heard
there was a goat's head soup and I
didn't uh I didn't check it out
um but anyway so we had anyway so they
backed The Blues Brothers and then when
they went when they took it you know on
the road National they had had Steve
Cropper yeah from and and duck done
fascinating to me what people don't know
is it started as a sketch and then they
it became the number one selling album
and a tour and uh this this whole other
uh this whole other thing and I remember
that record playing everywhere uh those
songs playing everywhere and it became
this Mania uh and and I remembered you
see this is an important part of my life
because you get started
76 I come along in 1988 and I have a
very clear memory if you brought me on
with my uh with my writing partner Greg
Daniels you brought me on and I remember
walking the hallways at night when I was
trying to think of an idea and seeing
these iconic photos
of the original cast the 1975-1980 cast
you know Chevy Chase
aykroid Belushi Lorraine Newman Jane
Curtin you know uh it just this
incredible group of people and these
black and white photos and you were in a
bunch of them because you were in a lot
of sketches back then they would put you
in sketches because you were quite good
and they thought let's let's use the kid
let's put him in there Bill Murray and I
remember looking at those photos in 1988
1989 and at the time I'm 24 years old
something like that and I'm looking at
these photos thinking wow
that was like a thousand years ago they
looked like Civil War photos yeah and
this is in 1988 and I had a very clear
memory of well I wish I had been around
for that because this thing is probably
at the end I had a very clear I'm not
being a jackass or being a wise guy I
just thought well this probably has a
few more years and I'm lucky to be a
small part of it but and of course now
anyone thinking about my time there
that might as well be a hundred years
ago to them now you know young people
today it's just it's it's amazing that
you were there at the beginning and the
show now is about to celebrate its 50th
yeah
I was wondering how they were going to
do that but um
but it is I confirm that it is going to
be as it should be
February of 2025 because you were around
when we did the 15th anniversary but we
did it in 1989 yeah and I was one of the
producers I'm going uh Lauren
the show came on the air in 1975
shouldn't we shouldn't this be next year
the 50th Anniversary I mean anything you
know because if you count from this is
the 15th you see you know yeah and yeah
but people don't think of it I think
it's because Prince said he would do it
then I literally think it was I
remembered Prince being there for that I
remembered it being uh and again I
thought wow I'm here for the 15th
anniversary of Saturday Night Live it'll
never make 20. I'll be long gone by then
probably dead